من القدس معنا احمد الطيبي رئيس كتله
الجبهه العربيه للتغيير في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي اهلا بك سيد احمد تقريبا منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب ونحن نتابع الحديث عن
حسابات وعن خلافات داخل مجلس الحرب بعد
مرور 100 يوم ماذا لديك من معلومات عما
وصل اليه هذا الخلاف داخل مجلس
الحرب
هناك هناك عده ابعاد لهذه الخلافات اما
خلافات بين نتنياهو وجنس احزاب مختلفه
الليكود من جهه وحزب المعسكر الرسمي من
جهه ثانيه وبين نتنياهو وجلن من نفس الحزب
ولكن رئيس وزراء مع وزير امن وزير دفاع
وهناك خلافات بين كل هؤلاء
وسموت وبن من جهه اخرى خلال الحرب كل هذه
الخلافات داخل اما كابينيت الحرب المصغر
او كابينيت الامني السياسي الاوسع وهذه
الخلافات تطفو على السطح ويتم تسريب
الاقتباسات من هذه الخلافات خلال الجلسه
يعني كابينيت امني مفروض يكون سري ممنوع
شي يطلع برا هكذا هو ولكن خلال عقد هذه
الجلسه انت ترى انه يرون ابراهام مثلا من
القناه
12 ينقل بدقه ما يجري في الجلسه غالبا
معروف مين اللي يسرب غالبا اتمر بن كبير
هو المسرب الاكبر لهذه التسريبات ولكن
الخلافات متعدده ضف الى ذلك موقف الجيش
موقف الجيش ايضا هناك اي
في تباين بينه وبين نتنياهو احيانا بينه
وبين ايزنكوت و جانس مع انه جانس هو
المدافع الاكبر عن قائد الاركان الذي دائم
الذي اكثر من مره تعرض لانتقادات وهجوم من
نتنياهو من جهه ومن وزراء الليكود الذين
يتحركون بتعليمات وايحاءات من بنيامين
نتنياهو ضد الجيش ورئيس الاركان وهي ليست
صدفه يعني مش صدفه هم يهاجموه ومش صدفه
وهذا مرتبط انه نتنياهو لم يعلن م
مسؤوليته عن الفشل الذريع في 7 اكتوبر
لانه يهيئ لان يحمل المسؤوليه السياسيه
القضائيه العسكريه الامنيه التاريخيه
لرئيس الاركان للجيش لو بنينا سيد احمد لو
بنينا على ما جرى هذه الليله والكلمه التي
القاها وزير الدفاع جالنت هذه الليله ما
طبيعه الخلاف بين جالنت ونتنياهو
الان عن حول ماذا اولا لا يمكن لا يمكن ان
نفصل ذلك عن انه نتنياهو قام بفصل جلنت
قبل عده اشهر خلال المظاهرات حول الاصلاح
القضائي او الانقلاب القضائي ولذلك في
ترسبات
ثانيا جلنت حاول ان يميز نفسه عن نتنياهو
لانه يشعر ان نتنياهو عمليا انتهى سياسيا
او هكذا يقدر ولذلك يريد ان يميز نفسه عنه
ثالثا في موضوع لبنان وموضوع غزه الاكثر
سكوريه وتطرف هو جلنت هناك تفسير لهذه
الظاهره ان جلنت هو جزء من الفشل في 7
اكتوبر الفشل الذريع لانه وزير الدفاع
ووزير الجيش ولذلك هو يحاول ايضا اطاله
الحرب كما هو بنيامين نتنياهو وهو من
المؤيدين لفتح جبهه وحرب في الشمال مع حزب
الله وهو ما
يرفض الغالبيه وترفض الاداره الامريكيه
ايضا نتنياهو وهي الجمله يجب ان تقال في
شبه اجماع في المجتمع الاسرائيلي انه يطيل
الحرب لانه اذا توقفت الحرب ربما سيتوقف
هو عن كونه رئيس وزراء اها لانه الشوارع
الاسرائيليه ستمتلئ بالمتظاهرين اليوم
فيما يتعلق بتصريحات جلنت هو قال جمله مهم
نتوقف عنده هو قال لا اذا توقفنا عن الحرب
هذا سيبقي المحتجزين والرهائن
سنوات
بالحجز ولذلك يجب ان نستمر وكلما فعلنا
القوه اكثر كلما زادت امكانيه تحرير
الرهائن
هذه اكذب جمله في التاريخ السياسي الحديث
منذ على الاقل منذ 7 اكتوبر لانه التجربه
اثبتت انه
المفاوضات بين حكومه اسرائيل وحماس بواسطه
قطر
والقاهره نجحت في اتمام صفقه تبادل اما
محاولات بالقوه العسكريه تحرير رهائن
واعاده رهائن ومحتج
تم اعادتهم جثامين ولذلك ايضا عائلات
المحتجزين والرهائن يقولون ان هذا الكلام
غير صحيح وفي بعد سياسي وشخصي لهذا الكلام
لجلن ونتنياهو واحد من الاسئله الهامه
المطروحه الان سيد احمد فيما يتعلق ب مصير
هذه الحكومه في ظل كل هذه الحديث عن هذه
الانقسامات والحسابات السياسيه وغيرها
بالنسبه لاعضاء خاصه هذه الحكومه او ما
تعلق منها بمجلس الحرب ما الذي يبقي هذه
الحكومه حتى الان متماسكه رغم كل هذا
الخلل والعوار الظاهر
فيها
هناك قاعده قويه مع انها مش متجانسه متبان
هي ال 64 مقعد الائتلاف الاصلي اليميني
لبنيامين نتنياهو هؤلاء يدركون انه بقط
الحكومه سيبعد اليمين عن الحكم لسنوات
طويله يعني اكثر
واحد عننا بالفلاحين بقولوا بعف يتحرك
ويصدر بياناته اتمر بنفير
اي لن يسقط الحكومه لانه اذا اسقطها لن
يعود وزير ولا مره
بحياته الى جانب ذلك في حزب
المعسكر الرسمي اللي هو جانس وا ايزنكوت
هؤلاء عاجلا ام عاجلا سيترك هذا الائتلاف
ولكن سيبقى 64 ولكن ترك
الائتلاف معناه تدهور مكانه هذا الائتلاف
وهذه الحكومه ولكن جانس قال بانه لن
ينسحب في الاخر سينسحب لا يمكن ان يبقى
دائما هناك وهو يتلقى الضربه طلو الضربه
والاهانه تلو الاهانه قبل قليل قبل ساعه
مصادر في المعسكر الرسمي قالت اننا نتلقى
ضربات و
لسنا راضين عن استمرار هذه
الشراكه صحيح انه قال في الماضي حتى
انتهاء الحرب السؤال ما هو تعريف انتهاء
الحرب هل انتهاء انتهاء المرحله الثانيه
هل
عوده فرق او كتائب او كذا كما شاهدنا
اليوم في
الصور الساعه الرمليه لوجود جنس وايزن كوت
في
الحكومه
بدات تقترب هذا لا ينعكس على جدع صعر
الشريك لجنس في المعسكر الرسمي الذي قال
انه سيبقى هناك فرق
بين هذا الوزير
وهؤلاء الكل يقول عندما يخرج جانس من
الحكومه الشوارع ستمتلئ بالمظاهرات التي
ستقول ارحل الان انتخابات او ما شابه ذلك
ولذلك هذه هي النقطه المحوريه حول مصير
هذه الحكومه صح لن تسقط فورا لانه في 64
ولكنها
ستتضاعف تها الفشل التاريخي الامني
السياسي الاستخباراتي الاكبر في تاريخ
اسرائيل الذي دمغ بنيامين نتنياهو وحكومته
باللون الفشل من القدس احمد الطيبي رئيس
كتله الجبهه العربيه للتغيير في الكنس
الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك l